foreign this is the Nancy Grace Roman
survey telescope or Roman for short NASA
is set to launch it into space in 2027.
and this is China's survey telescope
chantian that's set to launch a few
years earlier than Roman these two
telescopes are racing to map the
universe in more detail than ever before
in the hopes of solving some of
science's greatest Mysteries like how a
little understood Force known as Stark
energy helped shape our universe
potentially there's even a Nobel Prize
there right if you figure out what dark
energy is so we unpacked the technology
and design Behind These telescopes
because the country that can capture the
best images may lead the future of
astrophysics research
with the Hubble Space Telescope our
window on the universe
space telescopes are crucial tools for
avoiding the light pollution and
Distortion that limits ground-based
telescopes when they look out at space
from inside the Earth's atmosphere
an American physicist first proposed
space-based observatories in 1946 and
then about two decades later the U.S
sent up the first operational Space
Telescope the Soviet Union was close
behind sending up its own first-based
telescopes only a few years later
since 1990 the field has been dominated
by NASA's Hubble until the recent launch
of the James Webb Space Telescope or
jwst for short both Hubble and genuine
St are telescopes that look at a very
small part of the sky in a lot of detail
Jonathan McDowell is an astrophysicist
at the Harvest Smithsonian Center for
astrophysics he's worked with NASA and
has been monitoring space activities and
satellites for three decades they aren't
used to kind of look around and go oh I
wonder if we'll see something here you
look at something you already know is
there and you stare at it in detail this
is where the race to build the next
generation of telescopes comes in with
survey telescopes that can map out large
areas of the sky
NASA's Nancy Grace Roman is named after
the agency's first Chief astronomer
shuntan is China's first ever Space
Telescope and translates to survey of
the heavens in Chinese let's make no
bones about it they're both fantastic
and amazing facilities Quentin Parker is
an astrophysicist and the director of
the laboratory for space research at the
University of Hong Kong he's been
observing the rapid acceleration of
China's space program for over the past
decade you know surveys by their nature
throw up incredible things you don't
know what they're going to find
both telescopes are designed to learn
more about Dark Energy a mysterious
pressure that scientists believe is
responsible for the accelerating
expansion of the universe and the
galaxies inside it that will let us
understand how our galaxy evolved how
the chemical elements in our galaxy
evolved how we got here
but there are currently no telescopes
that can detect Dark Energy even though
scientists say it makes up around 70
percent of the total energy of the
universe so the goal is for scientists
to use chantan and Roman to uncover Dark
Energy Secrets we're not collecting
signatures from Dark Energy directly
we're looking at the way that this
interaction with things that we can
measure so U.S and Chinese researchers
are racing to build telescopes that can
answer the same question but each with a
different design one difference is in
the telescope's mirrors so if you throw
a certain amount of light at the
telescope right
um some fraction of it is reflected by
the mirror and some fraction of that is
captured by the camera Roman's mirror is
larger than shun tians which means it
will be able to capture more light
giving the final image more detail but
even though chantan's mirror is smaller
in diameter it has a field of view
that's more than three times wider this
means it'll be able to image more of the
sky over the course of its Mission than
Roman
Washington may have an edge on image
size the quality depends on another
important part of the telescope the
sensor module
the sensor reads and processes the light
captured by the mirror and sends back
information to Earth for scientists to
turn into amazing images like these ones
from the James Webb Telescope
so having a less powerful sensor can
create problems for the images that are
produced you
your sensitivity I can't see quite as
faint Stars things like that McDowell
says NASA's six Decades of experience
creating sensors that work under the
extreme conditions of space give it an
advantage over China's younger space
agency the challenge for China is can
they match the the sort of semiconductor
technology aspects of NASA's cameras by
having more experience with telescopes
NASA can also be more ambitious about
how far it sends Roman the telescope
will orbit the Sun from a distance of
about 1 million miles from Earth that
means Roman will be able to operate
without constant changes in light and
temperature and NASA says that allows
the telescope to collect data constantly
shintan on the other hand will stay
close to the Earth and therefore be
regularly blocked as it orbits limiting
the amount of time it can spend
collecting data but being that far away
also means Roman can't be repaired if
anything goes wrong
shentan will be near the Chinese space
station giving scientists on board
access to the telescope if needed you
can actually not only can you repair it
it gets damaged or if the solar panels
gets damaged or something goes wrong you
can upgrade it you can replace the
camera you can put on new filters new
instrumentation give it a new lease of
life keep it going for longer
however what could be the most important
Advantage is shuntan's launch date China
space agency says it's going up in 2023
giving it about a four year head start
on Roman they may steal some of the
Thunder from what the Roman telescope
would have done NASA said in a statement
that shintan's observations will
complement its Mission and Roman has
unique capabilities for the study of
dark energy
China Space Administration didn't
respond to a request for comment on
shintan's launch schedule and design
scientists say both telescopes will play
a significant role in learning more
about the origins of the universe
there's a lot of international
recognition if you you know if you start
to elucidate what's going on in the in
the early universe but only one country
can lay claim to being the first to make
the biggest discoveries in astrophysics